really funny moment on Fox News and I
actually I'm going to defend Griffin
khun's sort of Grif Jenkins is a guy at
Fox News that I've never seen him do
anything particularly interesting and
one of the things that he sometimes does
is he goes out in public and talks to
people about what they're thinking on
politics and okay we could sort of
debate the value of that what he did
recently was he was out at the tasty
diner in Bethesda Maryland and this is
shortly after Donald Trump fired FBI
director James Comey of course Donald
Trump didn't say it was because he
wanted to try to interrupt the Trump
Russia investigation but we can all sort
of read into that that at least that
seems to have played a factor
brif Jenkins goes over to this guy at
this diner in Bethesda Maryland and the
timing of it is hilarious because as
soon as the guy mentions maybe the
investigation was getting too close to
figuring out what happened with Putin
the interview has ended seemingly
abruptly but I am actually going to
defend Griff Jenkins okay this video has
gone viral let's take a look at the
video first out of line pad what do you
make of the firing thumbs up or thumbs
down on that decision well I think it
should have been done much earlier I
think but I think the be too
Machiavellian about it why does it take
such a long time for these guys to
revive this conclusion is it because
we're getting too tight getting from
finding out too much information about
the Putin is that well see thank you
we're entitle in time I just want to
tell you - we're going to be talking to
folks here Steve crecer he's actually
saying around
yeah well puddin what we're ty downtown
let's go talk to this other guy here in
a different part of the restaurant you
can sort of imagine the producer in
Griff Jenkins ear saying abort abort
walk away from that man the reality is
and I I don't want to defend Fox News I
don't want to go out of my way to defend
Fox News but this video has gone so
viral that I do want to mention that
these segments are pretty tightly timed
and more than likely this segment was
ending anyway at that point and Griff
Jenkins actually commented on this on
Twitter in response to Lisp our one who
posted about tweeted about this video
saying lists I always always open to
but in fairness I only had two and a
half minutes for the entire segment and
gave all but five to set 10 seconds to
him not a fair attack uh and I I think
that that's probably true what is the
point of these segments does anyone
really believe that this is a completely
representative cross-section of what
people think about any particular issue
I don't know I mean obviously at some
sense it is it is a guy who has an
opinion I don't know how much we glean
from these types of interviews once it
actually turned out Fox News did this
and they were interviewing some producer
or an employee of some kind of Fox News
as a random voice on the street and no
disclosure was given whatsoever but that
aside I was I was curious with this
issue of the James Comey firing what
narrative is Fox News taking on and how
can they cover the Comey thing without
talking about the Trump Russia part of
the story and they're basically just
pretending everything's fine since the
inauguration there's been this general
attitude with a few exceptions
everything's fine liberals are only mad
at Trump because he's a conservative
it's not clear as a conservative he
seems to be an authoritarian more than
anything and just pretending like
everything's fine and dandy and it's if
we we've done prior reports about how
acutely under-informed
primary Fox News viewers are if you're
only watching Fox News right now you may
not have any sense that this is an
administration that in its first nearly
four months has been riddled in more
scandals than the Obama administration
had over an entire eight years some of
those scandals non scandals whatsoever
like Obama wore a light-colored suit
when talking about something serious
your perception of reality could as a
result of mostly getting your news from
Fox News could not possibly be more
skewed than it is right now make sure to
sign up david pakman.com slash
membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show we're doing what we can to
make up for a 66% loss in ad revenue as
a result of YouTube ad pock
and every single person that signs up is
really helping to undo the damage that
has been done by many big dollars big
corporate dollars being pulled out of
YouTube and we appreciate everybody that
signed up or pledged in the last month
or so